hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben zuschauer ich habe schon sehr
häufig auf doppel reagiert ja ich liebe
diese frau auf jeden fall wurde nun vor
drei tagen ein neues video hochgeladen
mit dem titel get ready mit mieter mit
make-up routine
das
geil werden in meiner letzten action auf
sommer habe ich euch außerdem gesagt
dass ihr mir mal in die kommentare
schreiben sollte was ihr denkt welcher
satz auf jeden fall in dieser folge
vorkommen wird wir machen also heute so
ein kleines domingo mit diesen
kommentaren von euch wie siehst du denn
aus was ist denn hier los sie frisst am
anfang des videos was ist das denn
mensch dass du dich nicht schämen also
das sind die 6 kommentare
beziehungsweise 5 kommentare und eine
aktion und zwar das dumme direkt zu
beginn der folge was essen wird wir
schauen mal ob diese sechs dinge in dem
heutigen video vorkommen werden es geht
wie gesagt darum dass dumme sich
schminkt und ihre make-up routine uns
vorstellt
also es ist früh am morgen doppel liegt
im bett die klingel klingelt also damit
steht auf alter okay das doch nichts
gegen die ich persönlich aber sport
würde die vielleicht mal ganz gut tun
sie macht die tür auf und vor der tür
steht
[Applaus]
die sonne ist gerade aufgestanden es ist
halb elf altar was man aber auf jeden
fall gerade schon mal sagen muss dass
die folge losgegangen ist die folge geht
schon 20 sekunden und bisher hat doppel
noch nichts gegessen also lieber bot
ilias el hak sie dein bingo satz hat
schon mal verkackt das heißt den
regelsatz streiche ich auf jeden fall
schon mal durch hier mit dem tollen
silbernen edding mit dem ich in den
letzten tagen tausende von diesen lukas
meili sticker unterschreibe luca warum
unterschreibst nun letzter 2000 von den
sticker nicht schön dass ihr fragt beide
lieben zuschauer
ich habe nächsten donnerstag geburtstag
am 21
februar und anlässlich meines
geburtstags lounge 4000 luke rudis mit
einem luxus gekritzelten print drauf
jeder unter euch der einen dieser 1000
limitierten luke rudis am 21 februar
also jetzt am donnerstag um 15 uhr im
luca shop bekommen wird der bekommt 100
prozentig auch einen signierten sticker
ein signiertes autogramm von mir also
wenn ihr den holy cool findet dann
schaut am donnerstag gern mal um 15 uhr
luca shop vorbei wir machen jetzt weiter
mit der action
ich freue mich so ihr großer tag also
hier unten rechts steht schon make-up
aber macht die dumme irgendwie heute ein
video das den videos ja alles
aufgenommen aber wenn sie ihr großer tag
ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so sein dass
doch mal einfach der marianne i make up
erklärt sondern naja wir warten mal ab
die freute sich so auf ihr geht und das
kann ich auch für richtig nach
audi ag mariano und englisch alter für
sie total ist
hat die marianne eigentlich herpes hier
mein beileid die marianne stöbert ein
wenig rum
[Musik]
ich dachte hat die doppel ja die hat der
konsum aber das doppel sind da sehr
luftballons sie hat jetzt einfach
kondome aufgepustet all das mit den
luftballons nicht geklappt als erinnern
er hat doch jetzt ist das lied alter
marianne das nicht hast du scheiße alter
das ist ja ok oder der zwischenzeit
durchsucht die marianne weiter die
wohnung oder was jetzt geht es hier ab
bisschen ist das schlagsahne oder oh
mein gott ist das fach zu scheitern
so auch schon und schon geil aus
naja ich dachte man ihre haare während
so fertig aber die packt sich daher
eigene scheiße rein also das ist ja
wahnsinn wie die ihre haare macht er
dass sie doch geil aus ich bin ja
eigentlich echt schon ziemlich hässlich
aber die dome übertreibt ja wirklich
komplett ihre lage alter ich weiß gar
nicht was sie gemacht hat wieder an
meinen klamotten rum gewöhnt hat aber
ich habe ja auch keine zeit ich muss
sicher fertig machen
okay ist das als auch schminke hier sie
nimmt die schminke ok schreibt sich
einfach überall hin unter alle doppel
egal du bist doch kein clown das hier
ist einfach sexy und dann kam sie aus
dem badezimmer rassen jetzt geht weiter
die doppel stolziert aus dem badezimmer
der gewinner hat er hat ja geschrieben
wie siehst du denn aus und das hat die
marianne ja gerade gesagt es ist hanna
anderen du hast du hast in der heutigen
folge das bingo gewonnen der erste satz
der darin vorkam kam von der hanna das
heißt du bist hier die erste heute die
anderen sätze die wir noch haben ist was
ist das denn was ist denn hier los
mensch tonne oder sagt dass du dich
nicht schämst also mal abwarten ob es
noch einen weiteren gewinner geben wird
ich mich selbst angemalt hat sie den
gürtel hängen wird sieht die mal
anschaut da haben wir schon ein bisschen
aus wie ein vogelnest was unten so ein
bisschen blutet trümmer [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] nimmt denn die marianne mal die
wörter her
[Gelächter]
kein scheiß ich will mal ein video sehen
wo marianne mich drin vorkommen und dann
reagiert marianne auf das video von
donna é das wär mein absoluter traum
ich warte wirklich darauf dass dieses
dass du dich nicht schämen es kommt das
wird gerade wirklich perfekt passen dass
man aber auch sagen muss dass die dame
wirklich immer einen passenden konter
spruch parat hat für marianne da
kritisiert die marianne so ey du darfst
ja gleich wieder direkt ein arsch oder
sagt sie doch mal einfach ja dann
passiert halt auf er in ost wie so ein
kleines kind was immer die richtige
antwort parat das ist nicht sex die rede
vor der küste meter länger sein
die variante ist schon die doppelte
manchmal wirklich leid diese auch so gut
weil wir die ganze zeit rumschreit
zwischen kurz propos gewiesen
und die sind irgendwie angemalt ihn fix
ochse alter erkannt marianne wirklich
nur irgendein preis bekommen hatte die
das gros so doll aufgetragen das war so
kräftig ich habe erst gedacht ist rechts
und links gegen die beiden zimmerwände
klatschen das wäre ein bluterguss alter
eigentlich hätten wir noch so ein ding
ding wird reingehen müssen von wegen
unfassbar exotische beleidigungen von
mach ich dann hörst interessen geht
so geht man eigentlich nie irgendwo die
dollar hat sich doch ganz normal mühe
gegeben und ich finde man sollte als
mensch so in erscheinung treten wie man
in erscheinung treten möchte deswegen
komme
ich habe mich so geschämt haben wir
nicht was mit schämen hier drin xxx xxx
die werften hierfür beschissenen namen
alter bingo satz dass du dich nicht
schämen also es ist jetzt nicht ganz der
gesagt wurde aber ich würde sagen du
bist auf jeden fall schon mal der zweite
gewinner haben schminkt sich jetzt ab
mit so abschminken ausschnitt ganz kurz
war eigentlich schon verloren der gesagt
hat dass sie zu beginn des videos ist
aber dass sie sich wirklich beim
schminken eine packung chips reinhaut
alt haben mein lieber bruder ilias el
hak cie du hast den dritten platz machte
mach dir die frage weißt du was wir mit
den clips machen und chips geht doch
nicht dass man sich vom gegner voll
frist marianne
jetzt schwingt die marianne die dame
hier
wir schauen uns mal gleich das
endergebnis an wir sind jetzt fertig und
komme nie ans gehen denn ich begleite
dich wenigstens bis zum kaffee
ok ok marianne begleitet jetzt die damit
zum kaffee
das ist ja echt abgrundtief beschissen
alter steckt die sich in oslip sein und
wir hustet einfach damit die variante
dass sich mit gericht knistern als die
tüte rausgeholt habe dann einfach ein
bisschen husten überspielt wir haben
drei gewinner heute pana big six exil on
und basilia say hat sie daumen hoch an
euch an der stelle wenn ich damit auch
die heutige reaction beenden denn das
make-up routine ist damit ja auch
beendet falls ihr andere bingo sätze für
die nächste folge willst oder denkt hey
das wird auf jeden fall drin vorkommt
schreibt mir gerne eure vermutung euren
bingo satz und in die kommentare und
schreib mir gerne außerdem eine weitere
folge und in die kommentare mit dem auf
der ich das nächste mal reagieren soll
in einer woche
es gibt ja noch so krass fiel zur
auswahl beispielsweise bommel im
schwimmbad oder im knast habe ich auch
gesehen dass wir im gefängnis war also
schreibt mir da gerne eure lieblings
folge auf die ich reagieren soll und die
kommentare last einen like bei diesem
video da wenn es euch gefallen hatte uns
21 februar nächste woche donnerstag
kommt der neue rudi in den
[Musik]